With everything going on with the Charleston Wine
and Food Festival this weekend,
it was amazing to have the Moxie Hotel
host me for a stay overnight.
I love a Charleston staycation,
and the Moxie Hotel was so chic and fun.
It was the perfect place to rest and relax
between events.
The Moxie has an eclectic,
cool, upscale vibe,
which is perfect if you're heading to Charleston
for a fun weekend,
a getaway, or even a staycation.
It's in a great location
to some of my absolute favorite restaurants
like Pink Bellies and Melphy's.
They were also hosting the media happy hour,
so I jetted up to their sixth floor bar and lounge
to meet some of the other influencers
and media personnel that are
covering the Charleston Wine and Food Festival.
The view from the rooftop is
the best I've seen in Charleston.
You can see the entire Ravenel Bridge.
And their cocktails at the bar were incredible.
Definitely a little hidden gem
if you're coming to Charleston
or if you just need a night away.